i wanted to bring up this thing about
hollywood because i think this is from
the daily wire
i think it shows uh yeah whatever that
is yeah website or whatever
shout out apparently there's a bunch of
links on facebook daily wire
daily yeah so no no but i think most
people are not into this
the problem is social media has created
uh it's it's the foreground and people
don't realize
that it looks really big because it's
right in front of our faces
but it's actually really small so let me
let me pull some of this up this is a
daily wire poll
most americans oppose oscar's diversity
requirements they say
the majority of americans don't believe
in diversity requirements
don't believe diversity requirements
should be a significant factor in
whether or not a film is nominated for
an oscar
at the academy awards according to the
findings of a new survey monkey poll
commissioned by the daily wire they say
63 of respondents agreed
that films should solely be judged on
their artistic merits
while only 24 of respondents say
diversity should be a significant factor
in a film's nominee in a film's
nomination the other respondents
indicated they were unsure
nearly half of non-white respondents 40
said artistic merit should be the sole
consideration
while 38 said diversity should be
factored in
the nomination decision to me i am not
surprised the ratings are in the gutter
it's not just the ratings for for
hollywood cnn news outlets or ratings
are in the gutter
fox news apparently the only outlet
that's actually maintained their ratings
post trump
though they did take a big hit you know
during trump like
they had some pushback during the
election right right right
i look at i look at these these tv shows
and you see the ratings are down
you look at the grammys you look at the
oscars nobody wants to watch this stuff
you look at some of these movies that
have come out and
wow have they not made money birds of
frey did you see that movie
no no you're lucky it's not for the
flight back i should not
uh you do not want to watch that movie
no it is
you know the issue i take with it is
that it's all
based off of this um it's like it's like
indignation like like i'm
uh it's this anger yeah it's not a a
positive question
so i think back to like you know old
content uh old shows back in the day
that i thought were progressive or in a
sense or or or talk to civil rights
for things for kids that that were done
right i always reference static shock
the cartoon i don't know if you're
familiar with no no
i mean it was a kids show and you have
um this this
character virgil hawkins he's a young
black teenager he gains superpowers
the stories they go through are about
you know his best friend is gay
should he join a gang and it was done in
a very inquisitive way that explained a
point
today's version of of politics in shows
like wokeness and diversity requirements
are
bashing you over the head with anger
about how you're evil and wrong and
we're mad at you
yeah it's very very different from just
telling someone what what would be right
you know what i mean well i think
part of it is because getting back to
your might makes right argument
earlier one would hope that in a
civilized society we can all just
persuade one another through arguments
that hey my view of this social question
is right and so here's my argument
but because the left is now basically
abandoned that and and i don't just mean
they don't make good arguments and their
arguments are no good i mean
as a product of their radical ideologies
over the years they have come to
deny the reality of objective of the
objective world right they'll actually
say things like
objective truth that's actually a white
supremacist dog whistle
things like that so that if they're
going to deny that
then argument falls apart and so it has
to be angry or at least threatening in
the sense that
if they want to get you to go along with
their program they've just got to make
you
do it they're not going to persuade you
it won't be generally at what point do
you legislate this i was thinking of
this earlier you were saying like do you
have the right to tell someone
i think you should do this and yes i
believe you do when
if it's not a certain type of like
sedition or whatever
but at what point are you should you be
able to legislate i think you should do
this and that's basically
kind of what our government does and now
it's what our social media is doing
because it's the new it's one of the new
forms of government because it is the
government
yeah right how are they legislating by
like public opinion by like
fear-mongering like this juror was
afraid that they were gonna
well so so it's it's the anger it's the
negativity it's the rage
instead of the compassion so a good
example i'm trying to think of like
what's a really good example of how they
do wokeness wrong and how about
ghostbusters 2016.
have you seen that one nobody saw that
one right yeah i don't think i'm alone
here
uh awful why because
they think that the idea of of diversity
in movies
is being mean and nasty and insulting
yeah so they're mad that we do captain
america we do thor and iron man and it's
all white males
yeah i don't care that it's white males
i have no problem with you know shang
chi the new
it's the new marvel movie coming out
it's an asian lead with asian characters
i'm like
cool when you do when they see that
those three movies where it's all white
men
their reaction is to make a movie where
they insult and berate
and and belittle white men yeah it's
like how that's not social justice
that's just the same thing but just be
it just being mean to people you're
right
i think about a movie like wonder woman
the first one or
say like edge of tomorrow where they
actually just have
strong female characters to represent
female characters
and they don't insult you and bash you
over the head and tell you're a [ __ ] or
you're toxic or you're stupid
to me that's that's the main issue here
but well you i mean it's
a good rule of thumb i've found is that
when you're trying to understand
something the radical left is doing
just invert reality invert the
traditional order so
uh traditionally what uh humility is the
beginning of wisdom right
very important virtue what does the left
celebrate pride
not just not just gay pride it's like
fat pride skinny pride [ __ ] pride all
right all these
all these various marches to to embrace
pride
which a friend of mine once said it used
to be this thing i think it was thomas
aquinas called it the queen of all
vices and now uh my friend referred to
it as the vice of all queens which i
think that's very that's not nice that's
not a nice thing
it's very politically correct but it's
because it's actually it's way beyond
the gay question
if you look at the essence of
christianity what is it
that in this fallen world you have the
incarnation of perfect good
the actual god himself the second person
of the trinity incarnate into the world
to redeem mankind
what do you have on the left you have
the exact inversion of that you have
no shot at redemption no shot at the
incarnation of the good but you do have
the incarnation of evil
in in the character of the straight
white
man who knows that he's a man who right
it keeps getting narrower and narrower
we
yeah we talked about this before the
show a little bit moral frameworks yeah
and uh
something i've definitely mentioned on
the show that there are a lot of
liberals in this country who are like
if you need religion to be moral then
like
i'm scared of you know what you really
think it's or like what you would do
with that religion you must be crazy
yeah and the example of bill maher who
would say something like i don't need
religion to have morals
and they don't realize that their morals
are built upon the judeo-christian
framework
right of course well of course i mean
the it's always so sophomoric when that
when that fad
happened in the mid 2000s you know that
the new atheists
i i always felt the old atheists were a
lot more impressive i mean
i tried reading some of their books they
were sophomoric i mean they were so
shallow that they weren't even making
the arguments they thought that they
were making and someone like bill maher
yes
where does bill maher get his morality
from his civilization which is built on
christianity you can use the phrase
judeo christian whatever you want he was
raised i guess in a jewish household who
knows
literally like benjamin franklin and
thomas jefferson
you know individuals who are fairly
religious individuals
to say the least it's like it's built on
judeo-christianism and a little bit of
moral or
i guess you call it authoritarian
militantism
like what do you mean well we just
massacred the native americans to form
our country and pride
we're talking about there are certain
things that
in the bible and the torah yeah humility
and
the americans want to be a humble place
but what we that's a good place it's the
place that makes donald trump
they talk about pride trump represents
like turning american culture up to 11.
it's like yeah
the epitome of pride
it comes from i think uh decay
of that moral framework well where does
pride what is what is the american thing
with pride because humility is
is a virtue and pride is a sin you know
i actually i think america is a humble
country and i actually think even trump
is politically
one of the most humble politicians we've
ever heard not because he doesn't have
an ego he slaps his name on every
building he ever saw
but it's because he understands that
there are limits to politics and there's
limits to what he can do i mean when he
comes in he says look
you know i'm a flawed guy but i fix
things we're gonna make it a little bit
better conservatives traditionally have
this idea
you can't remake the world into this
utopia to me that's a very
very humble position i think we can rag
on trump for his character
and persona as a representation of some
of the worst things like
turning american culture up to the 11
and just really blasting the saturation
he turns over the casinos and the
supermarkets right right
but politically trump wouldn't send the
the
the military or the feds into these
riots yeah he wouldn't he
there were so many things trump should
have done he wouldn't do he wouldn't
fire people he wouldn't
force his way and they kept screaming
was a fascist
when he literally wouldn't do these
things in fact donald trump shut down
the child detention centers
yeah and joe biden reopened them
look trump i would not say is
could be described as humble not at all
what strikes me as prideful is all get
out there with his name on buildings
he's all like i'm the best like that's
pride and
we're told when it comes to politics and
the actions he took as a president
absolutely he was more humble than say
joe biden was
joe biden can rhetorically be humble
that's a fact donald trump was the
opposite of him i don't think either of
those guys
could to be a cult leader shuts down the
facilities you know why
donald trump shut down the child
facilities because the left was yelling
at him donald trump banned blood stocks
because the left was yelling at him
joe biden tells the right to screw
themselves well let me obama similarly
let me develop this a little because i
think pride
is an american virtue in a lot of ways
it's a catholic sin
but it's in the united states it's like
proud to be an american
and they teach you that as a kid they
taught me that as a kid that yes you
want to be prideful of your things and
it's
good and in a lot of ways it it does
help you succeed
in a capitalist society but do you think
when when i say
i mean it just seems to me we're using
this word pride in different ways like
when i say i'm proud to be an american
aren't we just talking about love of
country patriotism sort of an extension
of filial piety like
i i agree there's a degree of national
pride that's a really bad thing when you
say like every other country is awful
and we're just gonna
take them all over and everything but in
a way america
i think doesn't do that we bomb the
middle east a lot but i i don't know
that we do that
we kind of open our country up we say
hey man come on in we want all the best
from everywhere all
right we let in more immigrants than any
other country don't we i mean the
the movement of immigrants into this
country over the last 60 years
is the largest movement of people ever
on earth in the history of the world so
yeah well yeah people love it
and we let a lot of people in i mean so
much so that
now it's become very difficult if not
impossible to assimilate all
you're talking about millions of people
every single year and if you even raise
the prospect of hey maybe we should
you know like cool it a little bit until
we assimilate everybody
most people will look at you like you're
crazy do you think the catholic church
just told people pride is bad because
they wanted to keep control of people
it's no well pride pride made satan fall
like lightning from heaven you know i
mean pride is the
it's the sin of in the garden of eden
actually whitaker chambers ex-communist
who wrote this great book witness which
uh actually helped bring ronald reagan
from the left to the right
he said that communism is not a new
ideology communism is the second oldest
faith of mankind it's the great
alternative faith
that began in the garden when the
serpent told adam and eve
ye shall be his gods and that
presumption to be
as a god is it that is the bible story
that is what causes the fall so i you
know i think it's in the heart of man i
don't think it's
uniquely american but we've all got it
there's no doubt about that thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you